wait oh oh I see Oh
oh no oh no it's not easy being pregnant
hi hello Oh ask me how to avoid rashes
okay hello dr. Eggman you two are
holding hands oh no I wanna be done oh
it's a miracle it's a miracle someone
made this game oh please stop smashing
the glass no I need to get the hell out
of here why wouldn't I do that okay
boink okay I did it hello
can I please leave now all good on the
father who's the father
who's the oh hey what that's a little
bizarre but okay I ain't gonna question
at this point cuz holy hell when do I
capture the magic Oh what the hell what
the hell are you kidding me
oh my goodness gravy whoa wow that's a
thing okay boss
whoa what the hell that wasn't supposed
to happen hang on oh hi there you are
okay we got it good everyone's done and
tails was the father all along okay
gonna take this with me cuz unberthing
room you goddamn right it is
oh boy what the hell whoa
am I not done yet why am I not done Oh
No
Oh Oh what am i inside oh that's it that
should never be a question that's asked
when I'm playing a Sonic game what am i
inside for oh this is becoming
increasingly difficult to factor I am
still inside the thing that I didn't
want to be inside good thing I brought
this with me oh wow
Oh Randy Christmas Oh what balls what
and the [ __ ] is this
what is even any of this ok ok ok I'm
putting a filter on that bad boy because
holy hell let's see it's capture a
little bit of this magic going on here
put that down for a second ok I know I
need to eliminate this I wouldn't have
been able to see this otherwise oh wow
just get low that's good
ok that's that's good that's good that's
good that's good you want this you want
this are you the baby am I the baby I
know where I am I know some people have
pieced together where I is uh ok I need
to take this with me
good thing I brought this I had no idea
I was even supposed to ok uh oh no oh no
no no no Oh God Oh
oh so bad Oh God
you didn't warn me Aaron you didn't warn
me
I just got birthed there's a [ __ ]
baby [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hold this
[ __ ] here what the [ __ ]
got birth by rogue and [ __ ] this baby
ass horrifying thing first of all her
name is Ruth oh sorry Rouge ruse of that
day you can go to the wrap party now Wow
next video you did thank you that I
artfully done yeah I I'm glad I took the
Chaos Emerald with me I shot out of
Sonics butthole straight up look so rap
party man oh I can't wheels I'm just
gonna FAP to this for a little bit and
then well then I'm gonna go the rather
already a fat party yes exactly
okay we're going to the wrap party oh
well this looks nice so far I mean
everything seems to be a desolate
wasteland kind of like the part in
blood-borne Oh everyone's on fire good
burn it down to the ground it takes a
village
oh I don't want to sign the guestbook I
really don't know I don't I don't
BuChE BuChE well there we go everybody
we made a movie sonic movie maker was a
grand success I'm so happy that happened
Wow download content download content
okay there's only one more game that we
have to endure my roommate Sonic I can't
imagine how this is gonna be bad in any
way I don't wanna
my roommate Sonic is an autobiographical
game which explores a human Hedgehog
relationship set in a modern apartment
complex my sub roommate sonic was a
flawless first step into virtual reality
the Sega VR headset was never released
so this game too was buried okay
alrighty then I don't even want to play
this in oculus what the [ __ ] did you
just do one will you changed the
resolution on me oh crap okay here we go
begin oh boy oh oh well this Hey huh
yeah buddy yeah buddy I just saw a movie
of you oh hello
have you told your roommate how you feel
about him huh I don't believe you okay
cease life yeah carpe diem that Hedgehog
look out my window well what's that
hello Eggman are you hoping that I get
in this relationship just follow my lead
give him the tickle I don't I'm gonna go
home I'm gonna give you the tickles
who's gonna give you I said ow
password white glove white cool white
glove with a one and A three and a
capital G Beauty woman oh okay go for
the kill
what do you mean Eggman ah my noodle arm
what the hell's has happened let me
retract that back in there so what do
you mean by go for the kill
oh I see I gotta wait for the right
opportunity I guess
oh the foot oh he just shot rings every
Oh huh no no no I don't want any no
those are you no no please no I said no
mieze oh I don't wanna okay okay thanks
thanks Eggman just gonna get up come
stare deep
okay all right then
oh yeah hi oh oh okay I'm scared I have
no head okay
I got lost in the Sonic I got lost in
the Sonic oh okay oh good
oh okay oh oh I hope this is what you
would know I stopped getting what I
wanted a long time ago oh yes please
Oh Boop on that let's just Boop that
away cool bonus stage is this what you
wanted Aaron this is what you wanted
bonus stage
Aaron you want this come in here and
join me for the rest of this you want to
like just join me for this episode cuz I
don't
hello Aaron's here by the way hi for its
first appearance on my channel and that
weird okay so like uh you go this is
gonna be weirder than mates
roommates okay I think it's gonna be
well I mean we were just seeing there oh
hey why okay
what would you know you gotta get that
camera oh so I gotta climb up his crotch
to be able to go what's down there maybe
not exactly I see some down there okay
so I'm just gonna you can do it I don't
know if I can how you can do it I
believe in you crap how do I do it maybe
if you can't climb up his legs maybe you
got to bring the camera to you oh oh oh
oh okay wait wait wait come back here
that's so stupid it's so stupid
I lost it at the the orgy part that's
when things got really weird what
happened I brought tails behind the
building and then I got the burning
heart and I didn't know what that
symbolized so I don't get this to stay
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
brought tails all the way behind the
building yeah you didn't go back behind
the building there was an egg that said
like I love tails but I'm so lonely and
I can't go see a Moshe yeah then I
brought him back behind the building
pull it towards you man I'm trying it's
not oh it's just taking forever okay you
got a guy together yeah so you didn't
get down okay
no well I'm so glad I got that hi Sonic
how's your movie is it gonna look I
don't know what I want to movie have a
movie of a movie oh so I just wait no I
just movie of this one put a filter on
that bad boy nice ice we filled it just
using which will do exactly why wouldn't
I is this all I'm supposed to do Bri I
mean whatever you want to do wait is
this age is there something else I could
do correctly snake oh no did you not get
this either heck man
hahahaha
to explore I know I'm just like the best
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh well who cares
all right I guess that's school shot of
that for the last 5 seconds a very very
nice thank you I'll just get out here
now you did it was that it you're you're
you're leading me to believe that was
gonna be something unbelievably whoa
that's not the thing that I'm giving you
a secret oh okay I thought that was a
secret DLC dude this is actually really
creepy just the way that's like flickers
on the devian Ellison was Sonic okay all
right so what is the actual irony are
you able to get out of this window and
still record yes because it's just
recording window okay
so here to go into extra data files
extra data files go into unsafe use it
own risk boom go to corrupted data Oh No
open up Sega net okay
now I'll tell you the username AHA it's
MJ studio right MJ studio but do you
remember the password yeah it was a
white glove and then select your
protocol to be sega net hopes second
that wow you know you [ __ ] here it's
just I'm just doing it might be that
largest WH one two three
there we go yeah okay allow access [ __ ]
this is like legit Oh
oh my god you're signing on the second
night so you just patched your computer
to be able to go into second what the
hell it's so weird
there's a lot going on it's gonna have
to download some data first it's like
some next-level [ __ ] like I have no idea
I would never have been able to get this
all right so now it's gonna start
downloading some data great yeah cool
that's just totally harmless Abed and
then once it's done
one more there you go
yay that really do that it was it just
like any wish okay so that's running at
full speed though the toga it's very
dangerous
oh please don't mess around Oh matter oh
Jesus
all right it's not going too fast so now
we'll hear this little special message
for Wayne Gretzky okay cool thanks all
right go back to so now you're logged
into second that's it exit exit
so the first thing you're going to want
to do I'm gonna want to create your
sonic okay so it should be saved already
the song that you made yeah whose flame
the immortal hedgy sweet there he is
flame the immortal he's cute
thank you gonna photobooth photobooth
and it was like take screenshot on a go
upload a second it wait hang on only
good thing there that's a great job nice
thank you
yeah upload him second that oh ah you
can use him in the MMORPG
Eggman origin Dreamcast was amazing
machine really ahead of his son I love
the Dreamcast yeah I did too like it's
one of my favorite consoles upload
success okie dokie then I go back okay
quit dad
oh this so weird Eggman origin I'm gonna
Maury and then play play oh that's not
my guy so have fun
what do I do now you can't just leave me
oh come on
okay bye okay oh why does this feel so
much like Spore
is this like Spore is this somehow like
Spore oh wow I have no idea
hello oh you are creepier than I thought
you'd be how are you oh oh okay
whoa that is Oh
Wow oh no oh no no no no oh here you go
buddy
oh yeah I know it's just so good I'm
sorry you're welcome you're welcome you
over welcome back man so happy I could
help my loving child a mother's job is
never done
where is grandpa you know what I don't
know and I don't have time for you right
now
I got a some reason I can't like control
cameras
you want some of this you what's in it I
know it Stacy I know yeah I know I know
oh come on get just read you a little
more come on you got it you got it you
got all your chatter dad guys
oh yeah are you worried boy can you yo
[ __ ] okay all right eat it up eat it up
you're jiggling jiggly okay gonna gon
get you food you go you go you
insatiable bastard eat up you disgusting
freak those sounds aren't very
reassuring also you know I'm just gonna
treat an egg baby good you might get an
award I might also get a whole lot of
nightmare it's like that's just another
concern that I have in my brain you go
big boy come on eat up eat up eat up eat
up eat up don't eat me don't eat me
don't eat me thank you okay
oh okay I heard something about a
grandfather below is distracted by the
holy [ __ ] happening in front of me do I
get an award do I get an award from the
eggbaby I mean that's a big baby well
the music got a whole lot less
terrifying that's reassuring
I'm sure when I get to the top of this
tower I'm actually gonna have a good
time
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no okay all right okay okay
I was hoping for not this but it seems
like I got exactly this
sonic has the same that you have once
and she's good
cement name to paradise Marv Marv
Martin ma Mark Moo Mart Marky Mark mark
mark e okay Marky oh good oh good I got
oh good
are you good for me I'm so happy that
that happened that is great
cool cool oh I think I'm done I'm done
pretty sure I'm done pretty sure I'm
done here pretty sure I am done
pretty sure I'm done so that was sonic
Dreams collection holy crap
I think my life has been changed I think
everything I knew about reality is now
over and all my you know everything that
I've tried to accomplish up until this
point in my life is for naught I will
never be able to sleep again without
seeing Eggman reaching down to bite my
worm in my dreams it is going to be a
horrible time if you can play this game
for yourself maybe there's more secrets
that I haven't found which I'm willing
to bet there are thanks for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
Wow
you
you